good afternoon thank you for coming i'm
lieutenant david valenta
v as invictor a-l-e-n-t-a
me lieutenant with the special victims
section of the las vegas metropolitan
police department
reason we wanted to talk to you today
was to follow up on our tragic incident
we had last night which resulted in the
death of
a three-year-old male
in that instance what we have found what
the investigation concluded
was that the 25 year old mother had a
new recently purchased firearm
she was unfamiliar with the firearm was
showing it off to some friends
in an inappropriate manner inappropriate
place out in public in a parking lot
with other people and with children her
own as well as other children
right there in the near vicinity uh
which is highly improper and uh we
is a high risk uh during this uh she
mishandled it
discharging the firearm which did go off
striking her own three-year-old son
which did result in the death of that
child
we wanted to conclude that and let
everybody know what that investigation
did
surmise through all that she has been
arrested and booked
for child abuse with substantial bodily
harm resulting in death
and with that we wanted to go and make
sure the entire community though
learned from this took the message the
importance of this
because as i stated last night we have
had too many occurrences of this
we have had three other instances this
year alone
where people have died as a result of
mishandling of firearms
we've had seven other individuals that
have been
injured as a result of mishandling of
firearms
so two things i definitely want to
stress to everybody is that
owning a firearm possessing a firearm is
a huge responsibility for everybody
and it comes with two big things a the
security of the firearm
you're responsible for securing that
firearm it's more than
putting in a glove box putting a drawer
out of sight putting it on a high
shelf i can tell you from the numerous
cases i've been on
a teenager will find any nook and
crowning in a house
and there is no place that is considered
hidden if it is not locked and secured
so we want to make sure everybody's
aware that the security of that firearm
being locked being in a safe uh having a
trigger guard is of the utmost
importance
and second is the the knowledge the
handling of a firearm is paramount
we've had too many cases from everything
from cleaning a firearm
to target practice to children getting
access and playing with guns they don't
understand
and adults such as last night that are
just not familiar with the firearm how
to treat and respect the power of a
firearm
thus resulting in accidental discharges
i've been on too many
deaths too many injured people and want
everyone to hear that message and do
everything they can
there's firearms classes you can go to
to take to learn more about firearms
but it's just paramount that everybody
realizes
the ultimate responsibility of taking a
firearm owning a firearm bringing a
firearm into your house
regardless of the age of anyone else in
your family member
there is nothing more tragic than when i
show up and have to talk to people
about the loss or injury substantial
injury to another family member
that was preventable and that is the
biggest key takeaway is
all of these we are going to they are
preventable
we end up from everything from the
accidental discharges with injuries
also goes right into the suicides we've
had spike in teen suicides
and out of the 11 we've had so far this
year
five of those have been the result of
unsecured firearms right there in the
home
that a teenager has immediate easy
access to
and has taken their life and then
unfortunately on top of this already
dealing with the family talking to a
family
in what is one of the worst days of
their life after a
horrific tragic accident i'm then
advising them i'm
conducting an actual police
investigation and we submit all of these
gun cases
to the da's office we have an ongoing
partnership with the da's office
where we review all firearms cases are
submitted for review
regardless of the circumstances the
intent accidental
they're all reviewed just want to let
that know that regardless of the tragedy
that already occurred
there are additional consequences that
come with the responsibility
of proper gun ownership and handling
thank you any questions
uh the mother from last night uh that is
jasmine vargas
a press release with her uh mug shot is
being released
what's her age she was 25 years old
was the firearm purchased lately yes it
was
you spoke about uh having to see the
victim afterward uh what's also your
mind in the hours
after that during the night
unfortunately i can't really even speak
on just the amount of skeletons
i've seen in my career uh unfortunately
and it never gets any easier
everyone is tragic and it just takes a
while to forget
it was a lawfully purchased firearm by
her
that was perfectly legal perfectly
within her rights
she just did not understand the
paramount responsibility of gun
ownership
and the dangers you see you can spend
five minutes on social media
and you will find a dozen kids with
pictures showing off firearms in their
social media profiles
it is that lackadaisical perception that
is resulting to many accidents and
injuries and deaths
and then ultimately criminal
investigations
yeah we are in no way trying to infringe
on anyone's second amendment right
we are just trying to stress the
responsibility that comes with that
like with every constitutional right it
cannot be taken lightly
there is a responsibility with that that
gun
can take somebody's life and it's very
important to do everything you can
as stated all of these i've dealt with
this year
were preventable that is the message i
want everyone to know
preventable and we would love to prevent
them how long has firearm in her
possession before
uh fairly recent within the month was
there an incident last month involving a
two-year-old and a
six-year-old and so can you expand on it
uh yes unfortunately i said we've had
numerous of these already in just this
one year
and it was i believe thanksgiving where
we did have another unsecured firearm
where the person believed they had
stashed it in a piece of furniture for a
moment and then left the room
at which point um we believe a
two-year-old
actually accessed that firearm shooting
and killing
a six-year-old sibling
who was the dad of the man the father
no he was not any time
the mother was booked last night on
those charges for child abuse with
substantial
bodily harm including death
thank you